c'est d'ordre d'une pinède de la
campagne champenoise que s'entraîne avec
ardeur l'équipe de france de football
féminin qui disputera le championnat du
monde au mexique
1971 pour la première fois une équipe de
foot féminin va représenter la france à
une coupe du monde la compétition
n'était alors pas reconnue par la fifa
et les moyens sont plutôt limitées selon
l'entraîneur nous on essaie de faire le
maximum avec les moyens du bord on a été
pour la première fois la première année
la fédération vraiment nous allons nous
a soutenus mais quand même avec des
moyens limités par exemple on fait des
stages qui sont plutôt à l'état
artisanale l'état artisanale loin du
monde des pros c'est encore le cas au
début des années 2000 la première
joueuse à des rires professionnels
s'appelle marinette pichon et pour avoir
ce statut et vivre du foot
elle a dû prendre l'avion est allé aux
états unis dans le club de philadelphie
bon c'est que tu marques des buts en
france maintenant on aimerait bien tu
fasse la même chose avec
c'était aussi direct que ça donc c'était
un peu surprenant dès le départ ce que
je me suis dit j'ai pas j'ai pas le
choix je dois réussir
dix ans plus tard la majorité des
joueuses de première division et est
encore obligé d'avoir un métier à côté
comme dans le club de juvisy par exemple
des heures d'entraînement tous les soirs
épilogue d'une longue journée de travail
qu'elles soient secrétaire étudiante
pompiers ou enseignante difficile de
concilier vie active et vie sportive
quand on se lève le matin de bonne heure
pour aller travailler
on doit enchaîner avec un entraînement
de haut niveau le soir ça fait des
grosses journées
aujourd'hui juvisy est rattachée au club
masculin paris fc
car c'est apparemment la solution pour
que les filles soient sous contrat
s'adosser à un club de ligue 1 ou de
ligue 2 un des premiers clubs à l'avoir
fait c'est l'olympique lyonnais et qui
dit joueuses rémunéré dix joueuses à
100% dans le club et les résultats sont
là
la section féminine de l'ol est le seul
club européen à avoir remporté six fois
la ligue des champions
comme en 2012 les lyonnaises réalise un
triplé championnat coupe de france et
ligue des champions
même si l'ol reste l'équipe féminine
numéro un
les autres équipes de d1 évolue le
nombre de joueurs sous contrat fédéral
en première division a augmenté passant
de 23 joueuses en 2011 à 160 et lune
cette saison mais pas forcément à plein
temps certaines sont donc toujours
obligés de travailler en dehors du
terrain
[Musique]